my name is Ken Jackson and this course
is the history of the city of New York
it's and it's always attracted a few
hundred suits it's a very famous class
it's one of the most famous that
Columbia so I thought it was definitely
on the bucket list this is an experience
that I could not possibly have had
without Kenneth Jackson's class I guess
in terms of how its enriched my my
experience with the history of New York
you don't really get a feel for history
until you've been to a place or you've
actually experienced a place and and
getting such an intimate connection with
these spaces that we've been discussing
in class is just such a unique and
enriching experience on the right very
soon is going to be Strawberry Fields
which is the memorial that Yoko Ono gave
for her husband John Lennon who was
murdered its 72nd Street in Central Park
West just off to our right in a few
minutes we'll go past Tavern on the
great this is an experience that they
will remember forever I mean the city at
night is a magical thing and how many
will see things than me would then
they'll study them but they'll talk
about it they'll remember it somehow I
may get married but we've got people who
here tonight who wanted to go when they
were students at Columbia and didn't
make it and now they're here I took the
class 33 years ago when I was a junior
at Columbia when Columbia was all male
and and I wasn't able to to take the
bike tour because I was working two jobs
to work my way through college and my
daughter 33 years later is a junior at
Columbia and she's taking the class and
she asked me to join her on the trip so
33 years later I'm completing the course
of curriculum you also signed up for the
course because my aunt and uncle met in
this class 40 years ago and they're like
you have to take it if you still
teaching it and Here I am the bike tour
has been great I actually have not been
biking the bike tour because my
was broken when I got to the meeting
point tonight at Columbia
so I started I met the group at 59th
Street after after the run after the
bike part through Central Park and I
have been jogging so ever since
riding a bike around New York is awesome
the way when we came through Central
Park you get to see all the way down and
it's like you come up this hill and you
see the lights start to come up and it's
crazy
this building right here which looks
like an office building is not that's
wires used to be AT&T long lines built
building to them to Europe this is
really like a once-in-a-lifetime
opportunity I don't see myself ever
being able to do this again I mean the
people if this is the last one I would
definitely be thoroughly disappointed so
I hope there were definitely a few more
I mean that the legacy needs to to
continue